so it's my pleasure to introduce Tracy
Osborn Tracy and I were doctoral
students together
Berkeley I guess we overlapped for some
portion of we were each there for a very
long time but the overlap was okay so we
were sort of working on kind of
overlapping topics so we used to hang
out a lot and complain about fieldwork
and and advising and all the stuff that
grad students complain about so Tracy
got her PhD at herg Energy Resources
Group at Berkeley in 2010 she would then
went on to do a postdoc at the
University of Arizona in the school of
and now she is an assistant professor in
geography at the same institution so
should be talking today about global
environmental justice and the carbon
economy and she's also going to give a
workshop tomorrow on a lab that she
founded and directs called the public
political ecology lab or people so
please if you can and you're free come
to that as well and I'm gonna pass it
off to Tracy who doesn't need this
because she has none of it yeah thank
you very much thanks so much Rob thanks
for that introduction thank you Chris
and Sadie and Zoe for the invitation
it's a real pleasure for me to be here
part of this exciting speaker series
nature culture action hosted by Yale
climate and energy institute because it
gives me an opportunity to talk a little
bit about some of the work that I've
been doing on the commodification of
nature through carbon markets and the
implications for rural communities so
I'm going to be talking mostly about a
case study a case study in Chiapas
Mexico on carbon forestry as a way to
talk more broadly about the
commodification the increasing
commodification of nature that we're
seeing across the globe and I use a
political ecology perspective which is a
framework for analysis to look at
environmental questions that forefronts
political economy politics and other
forms of power relations but also pays
attention attention to geography history
ecology and the materiality of the
resource so at a moment when scientists
have identified the
purpose seen as a geologic era that you
know roughly begins with the industrial
industrial revolution that has had a
serious and a significant impact on the
planet and at the same time the Stern
Review has called climate change and I
quote the greatest market failure that
the world has seen I would argue that we
cannot begin to grapple with the complex
socio-economic dimensions of climate
change without consideration of
political economy which is a central
building block of a political ecology
analysis so in this lecture series
because it's also you know concerned
with action toward the end of this
presentation I will discuss some of the
work of the public political ecology lab
that Rob mentioned so this is a social
science lab that I lead at the
University of Arizona concerned with
theoretically informed engaged
scholarship from a political ecology
perspective and in particular I will
discuss how a number of scholars
graduate students and myself have used
the labs web page as a platform to more
broadly communicate our work as a
strategy for global environmental
justice climate change mitigation in
ecosystems and forest ecosystems is
certainly growing in momentum and forest
communities are increasingly found in
the middle of debates over land rights
sustainable development and the ability
of carbon markets should generate local
and equitable benefits within
communities the carbon market is an
exchange based mechanism designed to
cost effectively reduce greenhouse gas
emissions associated with global climate
change however when these markets
touched down in the developing world
they're also expected to generate a
certain level of sustainable development
in the academic literature the ability
of carbon markets to generate local
sustainable development has been
discussed in terms of fundamental
trade-offs between market efficiency and
sustainable development where the
efficiency goals often take priority
institutional political economists such
as Elinor Ostrom have argued that
institutions in the form of common
property land tenure can offer a
solution to these trade-offs allowing
for greater benefits to flow toward
local communities however based on
empirical research in Chiapas Mexico I
and what I hope to demonstrate in this
in this talk is that community
engagement with the carbon market can
affect the ways institutions function by
changing the processes and modalities by
which groups use and manage their land
thereby reducing some of the expected
social and ecological benefits from
carbon projects therefore it's important
to consider the impacts of the
commodification of nature on
institutions and specifically the ways
in which the protective mechanisms of
institutions can become reconstituted
through environmental markets ultimately
limiting the protections to communities
and the environment so toward the end of
this presentation I'm going to discuss
the relevance of this research to a new
climate and forest initiative known as
red plus which aims to reduce emissions
from deforestation and degradation in
the developing world and also includes
conservation sustainable forest
management and the enhancement of carbon
stocks one of the more concrete
decisions to emerge out of the 2010
climate change meeting in cancun was
that red plus was given the green light
as a eligible strategy through the UN
process although highly controversial
red plus is being rolled out as a new
strategy for rural development in the
global south and has also taken hold of
the forests in southern Mexico one of
the issues under heated debate has
turned around the financial mechanisms
for red with particular concern over
market mechanisms in California the
California Air Resources Board has
adopted a cap-and-trade strategy for
meeting obligations under a B 32 which
is the state's global warming solutions
Act California's carbon market could
include buying carbon credits generated
from red plus projects from a number of
developing countries including Chiapas
sorry developing country country regions
including Chiapas which is the state of
Mexico and this could essentially create
the first official carbon market for red
research from a carbon forestry project
tree planting project and Chiapas
financed through the voluntary market
can provide important lessons for red
managed
through our market mechanism so the
roadmap or the layout of the
presentation will be as follow so first
I'm going to give you more or less an
overview of the carbon market and its
role in developing countries
particularly through the Kyoto
Protocol's Clean Development Mechanism
I'll then lay out a set of key debates
key academic debates on the trade-offs
between market efficiency and
sustainable development I'll then sort
of talk about sort of my sort of
articulate my main claim of this work
and also the theoretical framework that
I use I'll then discuss some of the
neoliberal agrarian policies that are
taking place in Mexico which I argue are
essential for understanding the
emergence of carbon forestry in Mexico
and then through a case study in Chiapas
I'll I'll unpack this the trade-offs the
trade-offs between market efficiency and
sustainable development and talk about
the ways that the commodification of
carbon can actually shape land use and
the governance and forest governance in
in communities in Chiapas I'll then talk
about some of the broader impacts of
this research in light of red plus and
finally I'm going to end with a
discussion of the public political
ecology lab and the ways in which
scholars myself and grad students have
used this to comment on red plus and the
role of red plus in the California
carbon market so the carbon market is
the has become the faint the main
financial mechanism for mitigating
climate change and in 2012 the value of
this market was estimated at 84 billion
dollars although the global carbon
market was down 35 percent from the
previous year due to an oversupply of
credits North America's carbon market
has been has been growing driven largely
by trade in California
therefore California's carbon market is
being watched very closely by many
actors despite some of the volatility
the carbon market is considered by many
financial institutions to be a highly
lucrative arena for capital accumulation
and as such the carbon market is
characterized not only by
commodification but also by
financialization meaning that it's the
site of increasing specula
activity this is made through a number
of growing carbon exchanges as well as
various banks and commodity exchanges
that utilize derivatives and other
speculative instruments to boost profits
from carbon trades and this is allowed
for significant financial gains through
the secondary carbon market and in 2011
the secondary market for offsets alone
was estimated at six times the value of
the primary offset market and so when I
say the primary offset market I mean
trades that are directly connected to
greenhouse gas emissions so the
purchasing of carbon credits through a
an implementer of the project or through
the project the the producers of those
carbon credits themselves and so the
secondary market is largely associated
with speculative activity and it was six
times the value of the the primary
market so these types of gains from the
offset market alone has led analysts to
predict spectacular financial windfalls
from carbon trading one environmental
consultancy has argued that by twenty
two by the year 2030 the carbon market
will be the greatest and the largest
commodity market in the world with a
value as high as 2.5 trillion dollars
equivalent to the current market for oil
so while carbon credits are bought sold
and speculated upon in banks and on
carbon exchanges credits are produced on
the ground through various projects
including those in forest ecosystems
however forests are not only globally
important for climate change mitigation
but they're also locally important to
over a billion people who rely on these
forests for their lives and livelihoods
therefore climate change mitigation and
forest has been a highly controversial
controversial with respect to carbon
markets land rights and livelihood needs
of local communities these issues have
been debated for some time in relation
to carbon forestry but have been
particularly heated with respect to red
while the carbon market or cap-and-trade
is often discussed in policy and in some
NGO circles as the only politically and
economically viable solution to the
climate change crisis establishing the
carbon
it was not a given but actually a highly
political process at the onset of the
climate change debates in the early
1990s there were a number of viable
mitigation options on the table that
laid out a diverse strategy for solving
the climate change problem and these
options included a carbon tax
transferring subsidies from fossil fuels
to cleaner and renewable energies and a
market and of these the market solution
arose as the dominant strategy largely
due to us advocacy for carbon trading
and this was based on the previous
experience of the US with the market for
sulfur dioxide abatement the defeat of
Clinton's BTU tax at the time which was
an energy tax on all fuels and
industries overall preference for
trading which they saw as potentially
profitable initially wary some of the
larger environmental NGOs came to see
trading as politically necessary for
overcoming business opposition to
regulation and finally developing
countries came to see markets and
embrace markets as potential revenue in
the face of dwindling overseas
development assistance so we want to pay
particular attention to the flexibility
mechanism the Kyoto flexibility
mechanism the Kyoto sorry the Clean
Development Mechanism
so the Clean Development Mechanism or
the CDM was largely developed to attract
the participation of developing
countries unlike other Kyoto mechanisms
the CDM has a dual purpose so not only
the reduction and limitation of
greenhouse gas emissions but also the
devote the generation of sustainable
development in the host country so as
you'll see sustainable development is an
ambiguous term understood differently by
actors by various actors across scale
however the CDM stipulates that it's the
role of the host country to determine
whether a carbon project warrants
designation a sustainable development or
not it's also important to note that the
current market form of the CDM is
fundamentally different than its
original design proposed by Brazil the
CDM was initially conceived of as a
penalty fund to be generated from fines
against industrialised countries that
failed to meet their emissions targets
the revenue was to be used towards
supporting climate change at
and mitigation in developing countries
and although the original version of the
CDM as a fund had received broad-based
support among developing countries the
u.s. negotiating team pushed for the
transformation of the fund of the fund
into a market mechanism thereby laying
the groundwork for the entrance of the
carbon market into the developing world
and ironically while the US negotiator
certainly had a power and powerful
influence in the Kyoto negotiations yet
to ratify the Kyoto Protocol so within
academic literature scholars have
explored this question of sustainable
development in the CDM in a review of
close to 200 studies on development in
the CDM Olson found that in general
trade-offs exists between the two
objectives of the CDM in favor of
cost-effectiveness and that left to mark
left to market forces the CDM does not
significantly contribute to sustainable
development so many of these studies
that Olson reviewed evaluates
sustainable development based on project
product type where renewable energy is
automatically equated to sustainable
development and other projects such as
methane capture from landfills for
example are not however over time the
proportion of renewable energy has
shifted from a dominance of industrial
gases to renewables and this has led
many to conclude that sustainable
development has now been achieved in the
CDM but if we evaluate sustainable
development based on renewable energy
alone this can actually obscure some of
the environmental and social impacts
associated with some of these projects
so if you look closely just sort of
looking at the year 2008 most of the
renewables are in the form of large
hydro and if the you know if we think
about sort of the the cases of the
normative dam in India and Three Gorges
Dam in China we know that there's
certain sort of social and ecological
impacts that are associated with large
dams
in particular if we think about sort of
the inundation that takes that occurs
with it's sort of with the placement of
large dams in tropical rainforest that
inundation can cause the release of
large amounts of
of methane which is a very powerful
greenhouse gas and and and also we also
know that communities are often
displaced due to the placement of dams
so furthermore this understanding of
sustainable development can obscure also
the uneven impacts of carbon projects at
local scales evaluations of sustainable
development from the perspective of
communities has largely been analyzed
within the realm of carbon forestry
projects
so while trade-offs exists between
market efficiency and sustainable
development when evaluated in terms of
technology and from the perspectives of
state and international institutions
trade-offs also exist within the realm
of carbon forestry projects within
carbon forestry sustainable development
is often evaluated from this perspective
of the perspectives of small farmers or
local institutions with regards to
perceived socio-economic benefits to
local communities according to a number
of scholars drawing on institutional
analyses of carbon forestry while
trade-offs exist local benefits are more
likely under communal property
management so for example Smith and Shur
argue that trade-offs often exist
between the social benefits of projects
and their attractiveness to investors
community-based projects such as
agroforestry small-scale plantations
secondary forests fallows community
forest rehabilitation etc have the
highest potential for local livelihood
benefits that pose the fewest risks to
communities because production of carbon
benefits are contingent on the
collaboration of communities in
agreement with this perspective but
based on a large end sample Shara and
our garwal suggests that trade-offs and
synergies between carbon storage and
livelihood benefits are both possible
outcomes
however synergies are more likely under
communal forest management large forest
size and greater local autonomy so these
arguments are in line with much of the
work of elinor ostrom and other
institutional political economists who
have argued that small holders who can
communicate with one another
develop their own agreements
systems of monitoring and sanctioning
tend to distribute resources in more
equitable ways and maintain systems in
better ecological condition when
compared to government manage and in
some cases privately managed systems
however based on empirical studies of
carbon forestry projects within systems
of common property management scholars
have found limits to the project's
capacity to deliver on social and
environmental benefits at the local
scale so these comments come from the
Carbon forestry project that I'll be
talking about at length so according to
brown and Kabira they argue that left to
the market existing institutions for
managing and supporting CDM projects are
unlikely to achieve the objectives of
local equity and sustainable development
and Nelson and de Jong are less stopped
optimistic when they they argue that at
one level it's simply amazing that this
carbon mitigation project has survived
much less grown a betting person would
not have given it very good odds for
success and in my own work I found that
although the involvement of campesinos
in the carbon project has caused it to
be highly regarded as an example of
sustainable development in frontera
corozal the community which i'll be
talking about the project has largely
failed to deliver on the economic social
and ecological dimensions of sustainable
development so my key claims are as
follows excuse me I actually kind of
immediate need a stir when I'm doing a
lot of reading so they keep my key
claims are are as follows so given that
in many cases indigenous and forest
communities that manage land collect
collectively have been important
stewards of forest ecosystems in the
rest of this presentation I will attempt
to demonstrate how community engagement
with with carbon markets shape forest
governance and the resulting social and
environmental outcomes based on the
research the research of based on
research of Carbon Forestry and Chiapas
my key claim is that the commodification
of carbon reconfigures local
environmental governance changing the
processes and modalities by which
community groups use and manage their
land in ways they can actually limit the
the benefits local communities perceive
my theoretical approach is what could be
called agrarian political ecology and
within this approach I bring together a
grand political economy with some of the
with some of the literature on the
commodification of nature so through
this research I show how current efforts
to marketize nature are part of an
ongoing process of the movement of
capital into agrarian spaces
specifically I engaged with some of the
work of of Karl Polanyi
as I find his work important for
understanding why trade-offs exist even
in community managed carbon forestry
projects so in his well-known text the
great transformation the political and
economic origins of our time
Palani writes what we call land is an
element of nature inextricably
interwoven with mounds institutions
sorry did I say man ok let me start
again
what we call land is an element of
nature inextricably interwoven with
man's institutions to isolate it and
form a market for it was perhaps the
weirdest of all undertakings of our
ancestors so ignoring the the gendered
language for a moment Palani essentially
argued that land or nature is a
fictitious commodity which like labor
was not created specifically for sale
and therefore has social value that
falls outside the purview of the market
a key claim of polanyi's work is that
attempts to dis embed fictitious
commodities from society unleash social
dislocation and ecological destruction
that call forth what he termed a
protective counter-movement polanyi's
work is useful for understanding the
process of commodification which happens
when markets enter previously non market
eyes spaces such as forests carbon in
the lock and on jungles of Chiapas in
order to understand why communities
participate in carbon forestry and at
the carbon market it's important to
consider the impacts of the neoliberal
is neoliberalism or a neoliberal ization
in agriculture and land on communities
in fact carbon forestry in Chiapas comes
on the heels of a process of neoliberal
ization of Mexico's agrarian sector
beginning in the late 1980s early 1990s
there were a number of neoliberal
reforms around agriculture and land
both of which had devastating effects
for many company nose I argue that in
order to maintain their land in the face
of the fallout of neoliberal policies
some farmers look to the carbon market
for relief the 1989 neoliberal
restructuring of the coffee sector
included a gradual phase-out of price
supports and subsidies for coffee
wreaking havoc on many of the small
farmers in Chiapas in fact the carbon
forestry project in Chiapas began with
coffee farmers looking to diversify
their crop following the collapse of the
coffee market NAFTA in 1994 was similar
in its destructive effects on the local
agricultural market because Mexican
farmers have been largely unable to
compete with the importation of US
subsidized corn many have sought other
land uses that might allow them a way to
maintain a foothold on their land many
of the farmers I interviewed in the
carbon project indicated there's a
decision to plant carbon sequestering
trees was due to their inability to sell
corn on the local market
the other major neoliberal policy
critical for understanding the emergence
of carbon forestry in the region with
the 1992 amendment to article 27 by the
Salinas government so under article 27
of the Mexican Constitution land was
redistributed in the form of common
property into peasant farmers as a hitos
and to indigenous groups in the form of
agrarian communities because of this up
to 80% of Mexico's forests are currently
under common property management
however the amendment to article 27 has
transformed the Idul system in two
important ways first it's Lee it has
legally closed off any opportunity for
landless peasants to be granted or make
claims to land Subcomandante Marcos as
the Zapatista social movement has argued
that the that the impetus for the
Zapatista struggle has been to the
reform to article 27 that now makes
landless claims to land a legal
impossibility because the amendment to
article 27 has created a greater degree
of landlessness and landless peasants
increasingly occupied land that appeared
unused
those were already existing rights to
land indicated that their participation
in carbon forestry was an effort to
protect the land from occupation by
landless presence through planting trees
which demonstrates act at land use the
second way that the amendment
transformed the hee Dulce stem is that
it made possible the privatization of a
heated land
the certification and privatization of a
heated land is now possible through a
state program known as per city which
for some companies has resulted in the
loss of their land through land sale so
as I mentioned neoliberal agrarian
policies largely provided the impetus
for carbon forestry in Chiapas and this
is evident in the case in the case study
at the centre of this research thus
kollel take carbon forestry project it
was founded on the goals of providing
development benefits to small coffee
farmers hit by the decline of the coffee
prices as I mentioned previously the
carbon project began with these
producers in the mid-1990s and has grown
to approximately 2,500 semi subsistence
farmers in communities throughout
Chiapas and parts of the neighboring
state of Oaxaca as the project has grown
it has connected a larger and increasing
number of company nose to the carbon
market through a network of local and
international institutions including a
local NGO state agencies and a carbon
broker in the UK the broad project began
to enter a more commercial mode in 1997
when it began to sell carbon credits on
the voluntary carbon market through a
number of intermediaries a local a local
NGO and a carbon broker in Scotland
carbon credits from school la were sold
to carbon buyers around the world as at
night as of 2009 the local NGO has been
directly selling carbon credits to
buyers however as the project began to
enter its commercial mode it went
through a process of reorganization that
resulted in a de-emphasis of the local
Development Goals on which the project
was founded one of the key changes was a
move away from activities with high
youths value such as the growing of
fruit trees to a prioritization of a
change value through the growing of
timber species timber also became
important as carbon payments were
extremely low and irregular payments
were approximately 135 dollars a year
per hectare and they were only given for
five years year one to three year five
and year ten and so therefore you know
because of the you know because of the
the low value of the price of carbon
timber became sort of the larger the
driving force for participation in the
carbon market and in these carbon
projects so the main financial benefit
from the project is clearly derived more
from timber harvesting and not from
carbon payments the community in which
I'll focus within the school L tape
project is called frontera corozal
frontera corozal is a Mayan troll
community located on the awesomest Santa
River separating Mexico from Guatemala
and it's designated as an indigenous
agrarian community which means like the
hee hee doe is a system of communal land
tenure that operates through a number of
established norms and rules the
community is engaged mainly in Sweden
agriculture and annual cash crop
production but also increasingly in
rural wage work cattle ranching and eco
tourism nevertheless subsistence
production in the mill poor remains
central frontera corozal is also a
rainforest community it's located at the
edge of the Montes azules biosphere
reserve in the Lacandon jungle and the
LA condo and jungle is the largest
tropical rainforest in North America
deforestation is held in check through
the strict rules within the community
which allow the harvest of trees for
domestic use only harvesting trees for
exchange for timber production for
example has not been permissible within
the community however results plane
shortly estate agencies promoting
market-based carbon forestry have
trumped community forest governance by
creating a process through which
community members can legally harvest
and sell timber I would argue that based
on results of a carbon analysis that I
later discuss that forest management
based on exchange
may produce fewer carbon benefits than
communal forest governance which allow
timber harvesting only for domestic use
these practices have contributed to the
continued existence of the Lacandon
jungle the two lists have a long history
of traditional land use in the region
they're considered by many scholars to
be the direct descendants of the Classic
Maya civilization that occupied eastern
Chiapas between 250 and 900 AD so in
2002 about 25 campesinos from frontera
corozal began to participate in the
Skoll el tape project unlike the
original participants of Skol el tame
the main impetus was not the collapse of
coffee prices but the low market price
of corn resulting from NAFTA and as I'll
show participation in the carbon project
reconfigured rules governing land use
and change production in the mill but in
a number of significant ways the project
has induced changes in traditional land
use mainly through incorporating carbon
offset production within systems of corn
production and these changes have had
unintended consequences that appear to
have destabilized agricultural
production and ecological systems corn
plays an important role in coal lives
and livelihoods in fact the word cheol
itself means corn or grower of corn corn
is produced in a system of shifting
cultivation called the mill PO where
corn has grown for a few years on a plot
and then left fallow for periods of up
to 20 years the fallow has managed often
planted with fruit trees and other trees
of high use value and most of the carbon
producers in Frontera are producing
carbon credits in what's called an
improved fallow system where timber
trees are planted on corn plots left
fallow the problem however is that the
production of corn is incompatible with
the production of timber species the
soil conditions most conducive most
conducive to cultivation are
substantially different from those
required for the planting of and the
production of mahogany and cedar so
campesinos are mainly planting these
these species mahogany and cedar because
they're species of very high use value
in the region but there are also species
that are that are provided free of
charge by the state forestry agency
konna for however according to Nelson
and I areas supporting mahogany and
tropical cedar are considered too wet
for milk book crops and these have had a
number very real impacts and it has
implicated has impacts on the ability
for small producers to be able to reap
the full benefits from the timber so
these include the following some of
which farmers were aware of and some of
which farmers were largely unaware so
it's well documented in the literature
that mahogany and tropical cedar when
planted in semi monocultural systems can
attract a moth larvae that while it
won't necessarily kill the tree it
certainly can affect the value of the
timber there's also been greater risks
associated with fire as of 1998 there
have been increasing fires in that
region 1998 was a large fire that
destroyed meant much of the forests of
the Lakhan Don rainforest and said that
since that time fires have increased
exacerbated by changing climatic
conditions and deforestation in the
region one farmer described how all of
his planted trees were destroyed when a
fire started in the neighbors plot and
spread to his land wiping out his entire
investment and years of hard work
farmers also expressed concern that
after paying the high transactions costs
associated with timber harvesting that
the plantation might not in the end
generate much profit one issue of which
farmers were largely unaware was the
time dimension associated with the with
the production of mahogany a forester at
a university in Chiapas told me that he
himself had considered planting mahogany
but after factoring in the time
requirements which he determined to be
greater than 25 years he found that
mahogany was not economically feasible
for an independent producer and finally
while farmers are in theory allowed to
cut trees provided that they can prove
that the trees were planted getting the
necessary cooperation of community
authorities can be challenging and this
is because new rules of land use which
now permit the cutting of trees for
exchange are somewhat at odds with those
within the community that only allow for
the harvesting of trees for domestic
uses so when asked about the likelihood
of receiving permission
cutting trees one former carbon producer
listed a litany of prerequisites both
within the community and at the level of
the state that were necessary for just
getting that permission and in response
he said no it is not possible it is the
same as if they asked us to reach a star
no it is not easy to do I had heard this
concern from other farmers as well
so in essence due to these real risks
the inability to generate sufficient
income from the project limits a
socio-economic benefits that can be
derived for campus inos so as a means to
bypass local authorities carbon offset
producers have expressed interest in the
national certification and privatization
program called priscilly which they
argue will give them greater autonomy to
use their land and remove bottom next to
their ability to sell the timber
so again priscilla is a state
certification and privatization program
for a hito land that was initiated in
the early 1990s in some interesting ways
per se which maps and certifies land has
some overlap with the carbon projects
plan vivo process which also Maps and
makes legible small holder land in
preparation for the carbon market small
small landowners are often left out of
the carbon market due to the high
transactions costs associated with
monitoring many individual plots and
this can be also complicated by the
absence of well-defined property rights
the plan vivo
is a system that makes small holder land
sufficiently legible so as to allow
their participation in the carbon market
developed during the early stages of
Skol LT the plan vivo streamlines the
agroforestry process and reduces costs
through land mapping later labor
scheduling and the involvement of local
communities and institutions in many
aspects of the project according to a
staff member at the local NGO managing
the project the plan vivo is actually
quite similar to pro se they in its
surveying and geo referencing of land in
addition the registration of trees
requires clear land and resource rights
and per se they can and has served as
proof of those rights many farmers and
frontera corozal expressed interest
per say for easing the process of
registering their trees and the also the
ability to make decisions over their
land without having to go through
community authorities therefore through
the process of demonstrating land rights
which is necessary for entering the
carbon project as well as registering
trees for timber harvesting farmers
begin to desire individual autonomy of
their land which is now possible through
per se day the initial step toward land
privatization while carbon forestry has
in some ways served as a protection
against the fallout of neoliberal
agrarian policies by providing an
economic alternative that allows small
small holders to maintain a foothold on
their land through articulations with
land certification and privatization
programs communities become more deeply
enmeshed in the capitalization of the
countryside so given the volatility of
these markets and the high level of
indebtedness of farmers the path toward
land ownership and privatization might
disempower farmers and put them at
greater risk of losing their land in
fact the consolidation of land has
already been occurring across the
country so I've now discussed some of
the social and socio-economic dimensions
of of the project for the perspective of
the majority of carbon producers
interviewed however I've also found that
the ecological dimensions of the project
are contradictory as well based on a
carbon analysis conducted with the help
of researchers from eco soar which is a
university in Chiapas we found that
leaving the land fallow may in fact
generate more carbon benefits than the
carbon project in the region and we
found that the natural fallow
sequestered significantly more carbon
than the approved fallow enriched with
timber species so this is a single land
manager and we measured three of his
plots so certainly not a statistically
significant sample but it was definitely
gives you an indication of the argument
that I'm making and actually there are
some plans for a much larger and more
rigorous study but we measured the
carbon in three of his plots so the
first two were initially planted in corn
prior to 1999 they were then left fallow
in
99 to regenerate in 2002 one of these
plots are entered into the carbon
project and he used an improved fellow
system where timber trees are planted on
the on the fallow land so we conducted
this analysis in 2007 five years after
the the entrance into the project to
determine the you know sort of the
relative carbon benefit and as you can
see the natural fallow there there's
about three times the amount of carbon
in a natural fallow compared to the
improved fallow we also sort of did a
carbon analysis on a much older plot I
mean he knew that it was at least thirty
years old just to get a sense of sort of
with a longer sort of leaving the land
fallow for a longer period of time what
we might expect and we see it's about
ninety almost ninety three tonnes of
carbon so again not a statistically
significant sample but at least sort of
gives you an indication that there might
be some limits to even the carbon
benefits within within the project so
why might this be why might we see much
greater carbon within systems of natural
fallow well first of all it is a
tropical rainforest area so if the land
is not terribly degraded you know the
biomass will definitely regenerate quite
quickly but also as part of the carbon
plot the land has to be cleared of all
non tree biomass so there's a lot of
sort of reduction of the undergrowth
said that the timber will be a very high
tip it will be of high quality the trees
will be straight and this reduces a lot
of carbon in the system and also I
mentioned the pest moth larvae which you
know definitely attacked a number of the
the trees in this area so these are some
of the reasons why we might see a
reduced amount of carbon in the improved
fallow so therefore the point of this is
that the every day pact practices of
leaving land fallow may in fact generate
greater carbon sequestration and storage
than what's possible through the carbon
project so what these results reflect is
the difference between a market society
and a society with markets
Palani with centrally
with the need to embed markets within
society meaning that markets should
always be subject to and held
accountable to social needs this
represents a society with markets where
societal needs predominate and markets
are harnessed to meet those needs
alternatively in a market society
society is subordinate to the market and
social institutions are harnessed to
deep deepen the dis embedding of the
market the commodification of carbon has
shaped the rules by which common
property institutions manage forests in
ways that have limited the social and
ecological benefits expected from the
carbon project in this case of carbon
forestry the commodification of carbon
has required the following processes
which have resulted in the social and
ecological outcomes that I've discussed
so the commodification of carbon
requires first the demonstration of land
rights and this is articulated with the
land the land certification process per
se which I mentioned earlier the first
step toward land privatization elsewhere
in an article published in human
geography I show how certification by
itself can lead to the loss of land for
some of the most marginalised members of
communities through internal SiC land
sale commodification also requires
calculation of carbon which is a highly
technical process of making forest
carbon legible for the market
calculation of carbon favours timber
species over fruit trees because of the
existing civil cultural practice of
measuring biomass of which carbon is a
percentage when you're taking into
consideration the wood density of the
species timber species are also favored
due to the low price of carbon on the
global carbon market which makes timber
revenues important for attracting the
participation of compazine OHS and
finally commodification requires
monitoring and the monitoring of carbon
requires clearing most of the
undergrowth and surrounding biomass
leaving the timber trees intact and this
need for biomass clearing together with
the planting of a few high-value timber
species in non-diverse systems has led
to severe pest damage which is reduced
carbon in the system and this has had
significant socio-economic impacts that
I've discussed so through these
processes I argue that the
commodification of
Carbon deepens the dis embedding of the
market carbon commodification comes on
the heels of earlier processes of
neoliberal is a ssin and they re
insector harnessing social institutions
in the service of the market therefore
following this logic we can read the
commodification of nature through the
carbon market as part of a longer
history of the movement of capital into
agrarian spaces so how if people were
how people responded like what are some
of these counter movements well Palani
also argues that attempts to dis embed
the economy from society results in a
protective counter movement where
society resists the commodification of
fictitious commodities such as land
because of these attempts at
commodification five years after the
project in in Fronteras cross all about
half of the original members had
essentially left the project they were
no longer active members of the project
and in the summer of 2012 when I was you
know recently in Frontera all of the
project all of the participants had
largely abandoned the projects while
most if not all had kept their trees
intact in part due to their involvement
in red I did hear expressions of
frustration and resentment one farmer
said I can't benefit from the project
because I don't have the registration I
need to cut my trees sometimes I think
about cutting all the trees to plant my
mill but again these types of forestry
based mitigation strategies may
intensify under the California carbon
market as I mentioned at the beginning
of this talk the California Air
Resources Board has adopted a
cap-and-trade strategy for meeting
obligations under California's global
warming solutions Act and this could
include buying carbon credits from a
number of regions including developing
country of regions including Chiapas
offsets for Redd are now being
negotiated and if it goes forward would
essentially lock in a market mechanism
for rent as part of California's carbon
market California's market could also
align with a national strategy for red
plus in Mexico at the 2010 climate
change meeting in Cancun former Mexican
President Felipe Calderon announced the
country's national
redd+ strategy which aims to foster
policies across the country that will
significantly reduced emissions from
land use and forestry
however some indigenous and forest
communities in Chiapas have expressed a
number of concerns associated with
forests with markets for forests through
red and these communities have been
particularly concerned about how the
carbon market for forests will affect
their access to land and resources so
these concerns were evident from my most
recent round of interviews in frontera
corozal in 2012 in 2011 the governor the
governor of Chiapas began providing
payments of about 2,000 cases a month
and that's about at the time is about
160 dollars per month to members of
frontera corozal and other members of
the la condone community to keep their
forests intact 2,000 pesos a month
represents an important support for
families in the lock and dong community
so many appear to be participating due
to the dearth of viable economic
alternatives in the wake of NAFTA many
of the farmers are interviewed in the
carbon project indicated that their
decision to plant carbon sequestering
trees was due to their inability to sell
corn on the carbon market sorry on the
local market and this is also likely to
be a strong motivation in their
participation around red
however participation in red requires
not only protecting against the growing
number of landless peasants occupying
their land but also moving away from
shifting cultivation in the mill pub and
as I've discussed the milpa has cultural
significance for many Mayan groups so so
in other words putting an end to the
milp is likely to affect not only their
household economy but also mine identity
and culture the inability to grow corn
for Mayan groups like the chollas may be
too great a compromise and ultimately
lead to their rejection of bread as one
campesino said when interviewed about
his thoughts on the carbon project
he said no puede llamar Paulo I can't
eat wood in other words what good is
land if one cannot produce food while
traditional land use is one of many
causes of land-use change which also
include timber extraction
ranching agricultural expansion for
biofuels subsistence production in the
milpa was the only land use targeted
under ed and this is because it carries
the least opportunity costs as milpa is
mainly for subsistence production the
opportunity cost of replacing milpa with
cheaper u.s. imported corn is
significantly less than other and i
would argue more ecologically
destructive land uses that generate
greater income and state revenue this is
evidenced by the growing production of
African palm oil and jatropha for
biofuels and Chiapas which are
subsidized by the state and under
consideration as a potentially viable
offset strategy for California's carbon
market so what I hope I have shown
through this research presented here is
that the so called trade-offs of carbon
forestry between market efficiency and
Development Goals may not be a given but
are produced in the process of Carbon
commodification in this process the
social value of land is subjugated to
the requirements of the market in turn
common property governance structures
for land use and land use itself shift
in ways that could reverse the social
and ecological benefits associated with
common property management therefore
this research is important because the
governance and financial mechanisms for
Redd have yet to be formally decided at
the international level and the results
of this research demonstrate that while
communally managed forests can provide
social and ecological benefits for
communities and beyond there's need for
certainly caution if not concerned with
regards to pursuing financial mechanisms
for red which can modify carbon such as
cap-and-trade so given the relevance of
this research to current policy debates
and the relevance of much of the
academic work of political ecologists to
public concerns I've been developing
what I call public political ecology
public political ecology is the practice
of making research from a political
ecology perspective available and
accessible to a broader public beyond
the ivory tower and beyond the realm of
policymakers it operates from the
understanding that today's environmental
problems require collective action
and that a civil society well informed
of the broader political economic
dimensions of climate change and
environmental change is crucial for
solving the world's most pressing
environmental challenges I hope to bring
the public political ecology perspective
or the political ecology perspective of
environmental issues to a broader public
through the public political ecology lab
so the public political ecology lab PPE
l we call it the people because it's
certainly a mouthful is a social science
lab that I lead at the University of
Arizona that's dedicated to two things
first making the work of political
ecologists more accessible and engaging
to a broader public through the use of
social media blogs video photo essays
and doing so in ways that speak to
current events it's also concerned and
dedicated with providing resources to
scholars and students of political
ecology interested in public and engaged
scholarship we call it a lab because
much of this work is experimental we're
not necessarily necessarily trained as
scholars to communicate our work to a
broader public particularly through the
use of social media video podcasts and
blogs
however academics are increasingly using
this media and the people website
provides a space for political
ecologists to do so in exciting and
innovative ways so early this year the
read off set working group held a series
of workshops to discuss various aspects
of REDD+ and its potential role in
California's carbon market the read off
set working group or the row was created
in 2010 to provide scientific evidence
and sorry scientific advice as a result
of a Memorandum of Understanding between
California aqua Brazil and Chiapas
Mexico in late March the row held a
workshop on the social environmental
safeguards and benefits sharing and this
was held at UC Davis in order to weigh
in on this important debate a number of
scholars and myself all of whom have
expertise on red plus payments for
nominal services Carbon Forestry the
carbon market and/or the commodification
of nature in in general wrote a series
of blogs intended
to directly or indirectly communicate
about our perspectives on the role of
REDD+ in California's carbon market the
special focus was picked up and
reblogged by red monitor and Greenpeace
International and began a dialogue among
some NGO circles so while this type of
public engagement does not suit all
political ecologists for those inclined
or compelled to do this type of
scholarship the public political ecology
lab provides a space to host important
and timely research and creative and
thought-provoking formats and that's the
end of my presentation thank so much for
your attention and happy to take
questions I know we don't have very much
time but maybe one question well there
it's that hasn't you know at the
international level so you're you're
asking me about the example that I
talked about in red New Mexico no you're
crazy okay
exactly so the the case study that I
presented is associated with the
voluntary carbon market it's not
associated with the compliance not CDM
and it's not officially red at all okay
so there are pilot red projects
currently in operation in in Mexico and
that project that I talked about where
the governor was sort of providing these
2000 pesos payments to the farmers that
was not officially a red project either
okay so a lot of that money was actually
coming from sort of attacks on on it's
actually coming through sort of low it
was money provided locally through
transportation so it wasn't that there
wasn't
gnarlie sort of an international fund
that was providing these types of
payments and that's what red is right so
it was sort of a pilot project where the
payments were given for about from the
beginning of 2011 to the end of 2012
those payments have now stopped
there's definitely been continued sort
of negotiation to develop a more
official sort of red plus protocol for
for Mexico where multiple groups are
involved including some of the groups in
California are very much involved in
helping sort of the Mexican state at
various levels sort of determine what
the official red plus strategy will look
like so currently we you know what we
see in Chiapas are largely pilot
projects maybe time for one more
okay right so you know we a number of
the scholars let me just go back to that
last slide so you know a number of us
have also submitted our commentary the
same blog that we had written and again
this was based on the research that we
had done but we also submitted our
commentary to the row to the red offset
working group they were taking public
comment so we offered our you know
recommendations actually two of us did
also Kathy McAfee who's at San Francisco
State University and you know reading
the final recommendations clearly not
many of our recommendations were taken
very seriously so in other words you
know we we we felt the need to sort of
submit to the RO but really the point of
the public political ecology lab is to
engage the public I mean I think there's
a long history of scholars engaging
policymakers and that's not necessarily
I feel my personal I think you know
Scott I think that there's a there's
definitely room for you know for lots of
scholars to engage in the ways that we
feel more comfortable but I feel that
you know I'm an educator and that this
is just an extension of the way that I
you know I educate and now just sort of
reaching a much broader broader public
so how great question so how was that
actually picked up I mean really other
than sort of this dialogue within some
of the NGO circles you know there's
definitely not nothing that reflects the
comments of this work in the row but you
know we're hoping to really take
advantage of other sort of timely events
so this this some series a special blog
series was timed
with time to speak to the particular row
event on safeguards and you know but
also I want you to know that this was
the very first special series that we
had we done this was really the launch
of the website it's a relatively new
project okay so this was a launch so in
some ways we weren't no one really sort
of knew of where the where to look so
this is definitely a set of issues on
carbon Forestry read that we want to
continue commenting on and it might be a
different group that necess that picks
up a particular issue you know so it's
not like we only work on red and carbon
markets it's really sort of a space for
all political ecologists you know
depending on your your interest if you
want to create a special series if you
want to you know if you use a political
ecology perspective and you would like
to submit something you know while we're
it's housed at the University of Arizona
it's definitely open to all scholars who
utilize this type of framework and you
know the other issue is that this is a
framework that is not part of the public
debate you know and so scholars I mean
around the world in the developing world
have been using you know the political
ecology framework since you know it was
the the term was coined by Eric wolf in
the early 70s you know so this is not a
new framework but it's certainly not
part of the public debate and I think
particularly because of this increasing
commodification of nature that we're
seeing and this is sort of an area of
expertise of political ecologists it's a
way to sort of speak to some of these
these debates and not necessarily to
engage directly with policymakers but at
least to sort of have this view and this
perspective become a little bit more
sort of part of a wider a wider debate
natural sweeteners Paulo typically smoke
yeah an entire cycle exactly that's not
that zero carbon safe and possibly in
that mission
yeah that's together no that's a good
point yeah that's a great point
so exactly so you know in the the
improved fell and actually when I
returned I actually wanted to do another
analysis a carbon analysis of the
natural Paulo and actually what I
returned this plot had actually been
destroyed but it but it had been
destroyed mainly because of red so with
as part of this pilot red project that I
talked about that they were involved in
they had they were only able to maintain
plots that were five years that they had
made that were have been using over the
course of five years anything older than
five years I had to be protected so
because that five year mark was coming
up for this this carbon producer he
decided to destroy it because he figured
if I leave it I will not be able to use
it so but that's a really really good
point but the issue is that within this
particular community they have fallows
that ran from anywhere from seven years
to up to twenty years whereas the carbon
project is not it's about timber
rotations right so you know they in the
timber rotations are 2025 years four
rotations of twenty five years so yes in
some cases it's a much longer sort of
sort of system plantation system the
trees will most likely exist for a much
longer time and then there's sort of the
long-term storage in
in you know in furniture so you know
that's certainly an issue and yeah
that's certainly an issue but in the end
if you are talking about sort of a
rotation those trees are destroyed and
you know in some ways you have to sort
of think about the mean right and if you
think about the mean if there's a lot
more carbon in the natural fallow that
means still might end up being higher
we're gonna be doing a much longer so
the other issue is that we also did a
soil analysis a soil carbon soil
analysis and that this is actually we
weren't able to get the results but I as
part of a longer study we hope to also
do the soil analysis and according to a
number of sort of existing literature
and studies the carbon soil carbon in
natural Paulo systems are significantly
higher than in sort of plantations
forest plantations and actually even
sort of some of the work done in that
area sort of demonstrates that that's a
good question yeah
yeah yeah well you know I mean clearly
the there are increasing communities
that are entering the project I mean
when this community largely abandoned
the carbon forestry project it was sort
of after year ten after that last after
the last payment so there are yeah there
definitely are more and more communities
entering you know so it's easy to sort
of enter what you know you're going to
be getting some payments but it's about
the longevity and that part is a little
bit uncertain yeah but I mean it's it's
grown from you know sort of eight
families to twenty five hundred so
they're definitely more and more
communities becoming involved but really
it's sort of it's a question of sort of
the long term the long term
participation that that is a question
and also you know the project began with
coffee farmers you know with coffee
producers and in a lot of ways you know
shade-grown coffee makes sense you know
so they were growing these trees to sort
of shade their their coffee production
and the money that they were getting
from the carbon market just added a bit
of a subsidy and it actually made sense
you know in frontera corozal and in much
of the Lockland own community many which
is the lowland there's not a lot of
shade grown coffee means mostly for
subsistence production so in many cases
the land use that was being utilized was
not the milk ba and so there's a you
know while it I think in some cases the
areas where the project started I think
there's been a lot more success although
the the brown and corbera case that I
mentioned which was very you know which
found a lot of problems with the carbon
forestry project those case studies were
based on communities that had been
producing some of the early communities
that have been in coffee production so
it has been growing in the sense that
more and more communities are entering
there's
little bit of a concern about sort of
the you know sort of the longevity of
their participation and then there's I
think there's also you know it's
obviously depends on where you're where
you're looking
I'm actually hoping to spend more time
over the summer to look at the other
communities of the law condone a jungle
but I mean yes I do look at one
community but the luck and I look at one
community as part of the luck and on the
larger luck and own community which is a
group of three indigenous Mayan sort of
ethnic groups that control something
like five over five hundred thousand
hectares of the lock undone jungle so
they are while it's one group I mean
together with two other Mayan groups
they control a vast area of of the
region of the other of the tropical
rainforest region that exists so it's
likely to be a site for red Zowie
yes yeah exactly so you know with the
increased use of sort of domestic horn
for for energy in sort of ethanol
production we are seeing less of the of
the sort of trade of us-based corn so
we're seeing less of the imports into
these some of these communities so
definitely they have in some cases
returned to milpa production but it's
still not sufficient for much of the so
they definitely like continued to sort
of produce some of the milpa so when I
was there in 2012 in 2007 I mean they
were still sort of complaining a lot
about the impacts of NAFTA in 2012 they
were sort of affected by a whole other
set of issues and mostly that was sort
of some of the constraints associated
with with red so they have been able to
return to mil per production and so
there's a sort of a resurgence of milpa
in the on the local market but at the
time some of that production was
constrained due to the receipt of these
payments through red which really
prevented them from using sort of large
amounts of their up their land so they
were lured they were still continued to
use the NOPA mainly for subsistence use
yeah so you know I mean a lot of that
discourse obviously is very strong
within some of the Zapatista communities
and the autonomous communities you know
the LA condone community again like they
have access to large areas of land much
of that land is in forests so they have
a very close relationship with the state
because of this sort of you know
relationship with the state they haven't
been as sort of they haven't challenged
the state in the same way that Zapatista
communities have and haven't used a lot
of that discourse of food sovereignty
the the whole issue of the GMO that's
been sort of an issue that we see a lot
in Oaxaca I'm not sure to the extent to
which they've also sort of had the same
issue of contamination GMO contamination
and Chiapas I know that's been a big
issue in mohaka yeah yeah yeah good
question
any others Chris I wonder as a professor
in a public university the degree to
which the orientation you're trying to
bring for PhD level and graduate level
so basically how do I sort of talked
about this with in undergrad spaces okay
so I teach two undergrad courses I teach
a seminar a grad seminar in political
ecology and I teach 200 grad courses one
is a 150 student lecture course it's
sort of you know it's their introduction
to it's called environment society it's
really their first introduction to
environmental questions from a social
science perspective and you know there's
you know we talk about different
approaches to thinking about
environmental questions and one of those
approaches is political economy it's
also institutions in the comments market
environmentalism and so you know
population and scarcity so we we do sort
of really that's a course where I really
want to sort of train them to have some
level of sort of you know critical
thinking and to be able to sort of
identify particular perspectives when
they hear it in the media around
environmental questions so we we start
to sort of broach this is what political
ecology is through you know thinking
about the you know politically economic
sort of respect from it politically
economically politically economic
perspective so there's definitely an
easing into kind of thinking about
political ecology in my sort of more
advanced undergrad class we definitely
sort of speak more to some of these
issues I mean in a lot of ways it's sort
of framed as you know as a it's called
environment and development
and so I really try to sort of I try to
demonstrate the ways in which sort of
our industrial industrial industrial
revolution and the industrialization
that's taken place in both sort of the
global north and the global south more
recently in the global south with the
development project how those have how
we have to sort of think about this
development process and so the political
economy around development and the way
that the economy works in order to think
about some of the most challenging and
pressing environmental problems such
particularly climate change and so I
think climate change is the issue it's
the environmental issue that I think is
most conducive that's really thinking
about why political ecology is important
and they get it you know I mean they
recognize that and they're concerned you
know and really in a lot of ways this is
why it's actually through the teaching
of the undergrads that I even decided to
create the public political ecology lab
because they it was so clear to me
especially with the lower division in
the lower division class it was so clear
to me that they really wanted to do
something about it and they wanted to
figure out what they could do whether it
be recycling whether it be sort of you
know green consumption changing their
light bulbs like they were seriously and
genuinely concerned about the state of
the environment they really wanted to do
something and I just felt that that that
is clearly it's important clearly
important we need to sort of individual
action this is certainly important light
bulbs you know you know you know buying
you know greener transfer using greener
transportation but that is not enough
you know and without thinking about the
broader political economic dimensions
all of the changing of the light bulbs
will not make any difference when it
comes to climate change you know because
if we don't think about the way that the
market economy operates we will not be
able to
really solve some of these very real and
pressing problems and so it's not just a
matter of fake telling this to
policymakers this is uh it is a
collective action problem and it really
requires the understanding of these
types of issues to a broader to you know
with a broader audience and the
classroom really sort of made me think
that this is something that they're
asking for and you know I mean I I do it
in a way where they also understand that
there are other perspectives for looking
at environmental problems there's market
environmentalism that's one you know
there's a population and scarcity and
you have to think about it in complex
ways it's not just like there's not one
that is the answer but at the same time
I do feel that this is a perspective
that we're not seeing and we do not hear
and the public is not really aware of at
least not from the mouths of academics
you know and so it was I felt that there
was clearly a need because in where I
work you know at the University of
Arizona
you know these students I feel in a lot
of ways are a microcosm for the United
States and so I felt like if they were
sort of encouraging me to sort of
present something like the public
political ecology lab or sort of create
something like this then there's a much
bigger need sort of globally and they're
they're interested and not you know not
all of them some of them still sort of
it probably takes time to really you
know if you're open to some of these
ideas I think some of the students
really gravitate toward it but overall
it's been they they've been really
amazing and and they're you know they
they do really want to make change and
so if this is something that helps them
sort of think more broadly about some of
these issues then I say you know think
about it and make the decision for
yourself